have you guys ever been caught doing the
deed yes you and Travis attempted to get
married in Las Vegas
do you regret not inviting any of your
siblings there I do not
she's being truthful the truth will set
you free or in the case of Chloe and
Kourtney Kardashian it will make things
hilariously awkward and shockingly
revealing own whatever it is the sisters
are the latest Libs to sit down for an
interview while strapped to a lie
detector for a polygraph test with
Vanity Fair and they go there all the
way there answering all of each other's
burning questions
whatever happens happens the first big
reveal comes courtesy of Chloe after
court asks her to weigh in on her May
wedding to Travis Barker did you like my
wedding dress
it was fine court and Travis tied the
knot in Italy tort wearing a custom
white lace Dolce Gabbana corseted mini
dress she accessorized the look with
lace pumps a pair of gloves and a
cathedral-length lace veil featuring an
embroidered Virgin Mary
I mean it was beautiful
for sure I just would have loved to seen
you in that at the after party and then
something prior and speaking of Travis
while Khloe has her sister hooked up to
a lie detector she uses the opportunity
to address the push founder and the
Blink 182 drummer's famous PDA
I don't personally
does Travis have a foot fetish for your
feet Yes yes well that would explain
this instapost and this one oh and this
post and this one too we're just you
know living our best lives on Halloween
in your costumes did you guys have sex
in character not this year but last year
what were you guys last year like True
Romance yeah last year Courtney and
Travis dressed up as Patricia Arquette's
character Alabama and Christian Slater's
character Clarence from the 1993 flick
it's better to have a gun and not needed
than a needed gotten not have it Bud
back to the lie detector oh God people
know so much about me how could I give
more about myself once it's Coco's turn
to sit in the hot seat Court who shares
three kiddos with her ex Scott Disick
tries to get down to the bottom of this
mystery are you ever gonna let true
sleep over at my house probably not okay
and is that because we have too much fun
no like still what is the reason then I
don't think we have enough time on this
show for what the reason is okay of
course Chloe shares her four-year-old
daughter with her ex Tristan Thompson my
favorite part about being a mom it's
complete Bliss the two split for good
last year after Chloe learned he cheated
and had a baby with someone else on
season two of the family's Hulu series
Chloe revealed that they did an embryo
transfer to have a baby via surrogate
just days before news broke of his
latest infidelity it was definitely very
angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled the exes welcome to their
newborn son in July and if you had any
question about the status of her
relationship with Tristan well you're
not alone because Courtney does too are
you sleeping with Tristan no I am not
I'm really not Sam yes that's true Bravo
[Music]
thank you